ben oui c'est une très bonne chose que
les intermittents puis certains de
l'année prochaine afin de calculer le
other en tout cas ici pour nous en
martinique c'est très difficile d'être
intermittents parce qu'il n'ya pas
beaucoup de cachet déclaré et
personnellement je ne suis pas
intermittents en tout cas en europe on
aussi la même idée vaut l'école parce
que je pense que ce n'est pas la peine
que les enfants aillent à l'école pour
deux mois est bon il fallait mieux
europe en septembre être plus sûr de la
sécurité mais sont prêts c'est tellement
de nous faire recommencer l'économie et
de nous redonner le vaccin quand ça va
arriver
donc voilà je pense que tout ça c'est de
la fumée dans nos yeux pour nous
distraire ailleurs il nous empêcher de
regarder là où il faut regarder